Mulder: "You said a man's behind this"
Mulder: "It's only half the story."
Mulder: "He wants to exterminate humanity."
"Leave it alone, Mulder."
Mulder: "What does he want with my son?"
"Nothing hurts like the truth." [Laughter, cackles]
[Breathes] ... [Beep as button pressed] ... [Buzzer sounds]
Scully: "I've seen how it begins."
Scully: "We need your help, even if we don't trust you."
Scully: "Mulder..."
Scully: "I've seen how..."
Scully: "I've seen how it begins."
CSM: "I'm here to offer you a deal."
CSM: "Civilisation is in its final stages."
CSM: "I'm asking you to betray the whole human race."
"Do you mind if I smoke?"
"Kill him, before he kills us all."
"We want to save humanity."
Mulder: "You want to see blood on the streets. The extermination of seven billion people"
Scully: "I have to find our son."
Langley: "Mulder! They know that we know!"
Scully: "We need your help."
Scully: "Even if we don't trust you."
Skinner: "How did we get here?"
"He needs the boy, Mr Mulder."
Mulder: "My son is none of your business."
"He's a very special child."
Scully: "William"
Scully: "Aah!" (as if in pain)
Scully: "You have to find him...
... and you have to stop him...
... before he unleashes hell on earth."
Scully: "The truth still lies in the X-Files, Mulder."